hello today we're talking about Lumiere
A Spacetime diffusion model for video
Generation by Google research this paper
is it's pretty insane so you put in text
and you get out video and there are some
other of these models around and I find
them all impressive but just look at
this so the text to image models have
become so good that the next Frontier is
now text to video so you input a text
you can see the prompts here if I tap on
these uh and from that every single
Pixel that you see is just hallucinated
from the text prompt which is insane um
so and you can see this goes from sort
of minimal motion um to quite large
changes in sort of the pixels of the
image for example fisheye lenses for the
dog or background sort of camera pans
around the car right here quite dramatic
pens so this it's I have to say it's
quite impressive also note that it says
a red Lamborghini coming around a bend
in a Mountain Road but the model sort of
puts racing racing strips uh next to the
car which I find quite amusing um the
Learned correlation there uh yeah
so this is it's certainly a step up
from what we've seen before also things
like the fluids on the ice cream and so
on um these these look look already
quite quite good and if you compare them
to text to video models from like one or
two years ago the the advantage is
dramatic um I know there are things
Works around stable diffusion that are
also very impressive so this is not to
be said that this is the only impressive
model currently in in
existence once they have this model this
text to video model they can then do
different things with it such as image
to video so provide the first frame plus
a prompt um the first frame could be
real could also be generated and then
sort of the the model will continue the
video uh from that first frame according
to the prompt you can do styliz
generation and that is something really
really cool uh what we'll see in the
paper is they built the whole thing on a
pre-trained text to image model which
means they essentially just add a few
parameters on top of something like
stable diffusion or or imagine or
something like this um and when when
they now have their trained video model
that makes videos like you saw above
they can swap out those pre-trained
weights uh and if you swap them out with
like some stylized image generator you
get a video in that style now that alone
isn't very like that alone is cool but
but it's not like oh wow but look at
this so you don't fine-tune anything so
the same text to video model that before
generated these realistic scenes now
generates scenes in the style but also
depending on the style sort of how the
video is conceptualized changes so this
here this is just like I would guess
regular videos like you would expect but
if you look at for example this here the
the the whole con concept of the video
changes to a sequence of stroke drawings
right this is the same model but just
because the image features are now ones
of drawings the video generation adapts
and now learns to to to produce drawing
videos uh if you swap in there other
examples um if you swap in this
watercolor okay this looks still quite
videoy but but if you see here you sort
of first get the shapes and then it
colors them in uh I find that to be
really cool that by just swapping out
the style you sort of the video part the
the video portion without fine-tuning it
adapts to the style and changes the how
the like the con concept of the videos
themselves not sure if everyone
understood what I'm getting at but I
find that to be very very cool and with
a bit of fine-tuning you can achieve
other stuff like masked masked um video
generation uh uh video in painting and
so on that the website here kind of
crashes on uh on the iPad so yeah this
is one of the things you can do you can
say please constrain the the generation
to a mask it's kind of a soft constraint
so as you can see sometimes you can see
some pixels are still generated or
changed even outside of that that mask
but uh you can sort of fine-tune and
teach it to do that all right let's dive
into the paper before this completely
crashes uh This Is lumier A Spacetime
diffusion model for radio generation as
I said uh by Google research researchers
have different affiliations but as far
as I understand the work was done while
there sorry I realized you uh the video
feed wasn't up to date should be fine
now all right so the the um the paper
is has a large part on the architecture
of the model and then what you can do
with it it has a most minimal part on
sort of what the data set is how they
trained it and so on how long so if you
came here and thought we're in science
and in science we're supposed to you
know describe in a reproducible fashion
what we did you're at the wrong place
I'm I'm not sure that's just not science
anymore if you work at one of the big
tech companies uh what you do is you
write your paper to be marketing pieces
uh so this is slightly better here than
like
gp4 but slightly at least they give us
the
architecture all right um they say they
claim or they they they start out by
just briefly describing what they did
they say we make a model an architecture
uh that generates an entire temporal
duration of the video at once this is in
contrast to previous approaches which
first uh synthesized key frames and then
kind of filled in the the in between of
the key frames which is called temporal
super
resolution uh after the fact because
they do that they get more globally
consistent and um they get more globally
consistent more smooth motion they don't
get some artifacts that you get when you
first generate key frames and it just I
guess looks better you're going to see
that it they extend the unet
architecture unet you might know from
image processing they extend the unet
architecture to also compress in the
time uh Direction and by that can now
generate a globally consistent video
they can generate all the frames at
once important thing is all of this is
built on top of a pre-trained text to
image diffusion model okay so the the
core part of this is a pre-trained fixed
they don't touch the weights of the
pre-trained text to image model that
they're using so think of something like
stable diffusion or something like this
they what they do is they make a process
called inflation and by that they mean
they use they kind of build things
around a pre-trained text to image model
that allows them to generate video from
it um I want to
actually maybe this part is good uh they
describe what the problem is if you
generate key frames so in in ye olden
days and they have they have Graphics
here in ye olden days what you would do
is okay this is your this is your
training sample up here um yeah up there
is the training sample what you would do
is you would have a base model that
generates key frames okay this this this
this is a key frame and then you would
use this temporal super resolution to
fill in the in between frames between
the key frames and then you again you'd
have key frames and so on you'd have
temporal super resolution filling in
those frames and after that you have
what's called spatial super resolution
to to make the images
bigger usually these video models they
operate at an extremely low resolution
you can see 128 by 128 and in the
classic way you you choose to operate at
a low resolution in space and at a low
resolution in time right so you generate
distant key frames and at low resolution
pixels and then you first fill
in the frames between the key frames and
then you do super resolution in the
spatial Direction it's a very sensible
approach but it does have some problems
so again what these models would do is
uh they say Okay generate the key frames
first and then I'll generate the in
between thing
here what's the problem with this the
problem is
um there are artifacts that can happen
uh when you do that for example this
here shows an image where a ball is here
and then this here shows the image where
the ball is there now it could have gone
sort of here it was initially right
could have gone this way could have gone
this way could have gone this way here
there is no way of knowing if you just
produce the key frames so the model that
decides to fill in these frames right
here has to decide on one of the ways
now that's that's not problematic per se
right as long as it does so kind of
consistently says okay I'm going to
choose this one and then it just
generates the key frames here in
according to what it chooses the problem
becomes if now the model that looks at
this part right here
uh makes another decision that is not in
agreement with the model that looks at
the first
part because you can't look at all the
frames at the same time because of
memory constraints uh you do have to
make decisions so and you do have to
restrict your field of view and so it
could be that the model looks at this
part and this part they make locally
completely good decisions however they
don't agree with each other what I mean
by that is they have a Graphic right
here where they analyze this so in this
part they have imagine video which I
suppose does this key frame technique
and the way to read these Graphics is
here is a generated video and what they
do is they look at just one x coordinate
like the one with the green line they
take just the pixel values of that X
coordinate of the first frame and they
put them here and then they take the
pixel values of the same x coordinate at
the second frame and they put them here
and so on so what you see at the bottom
is essentially uh time slices across the
video of just a single x coordinate now
you can see that the video displays this
humanoid thing walking so what you would
expect is you would expect sort of a
foot going forward going back so kind of
a continuous motion however what you see
is this you go up up and then all of a
sudden you can see it goes up again so
you would expect that here it should go
like should go on like this but you can
kind of see it it Janks around and
doesn't do that and then here also you
get some artifacts where it's like up
okay now but I stay here and then I go
up again
this is because you can imagine maybe
maybe I don't know but I guess one can
imagine that there is a key frame right
here and a key frame right here and a
key frame right here and the model that
makes the decision that the left leg
goes up here and the model that makes
the decision that the left leg goes up
again they don't see each other it's
completely consistent with all of the
key frames um so and the decisions are
locally consistent however they are not
consistent in a global sense in the
sense that the motion goes on like
periodically this is you know small
things to bicker about all in all but it
does make for quite janky videos in that
sense and you have the feeling of there
not being a global consistency to these
videos if you look at their examples I
don't know how cherry pick they are
exactly but you can see that now we do
get relatively smooth and continuous and
globally consistent Motion in these
things now how much of this is really
due to how they train it how much of
this is due to whether or not in their
training data there there was more of
that type of motion or anything like
this who knows like really who knows
whether that's due to you know all they
did here was probably take the first
frame and did conditional video
generation based on the first frame and
the same prompts but obviously the
videos here are going to be kind of
different and you can see from this
parts right here um being not constant
while these parts here are constant that
the right hand side seems to do some
camera panning or something like this so
there's so many kind of differences
between these things that it is hard to
say where exactly the Improvement comes
from but we're just going to believe
them
that key frame based models have the
problems on the left hand side um where
you don't have Global consistency and if
you do anything to achieve that Global
consistency between all the frames then
you can get more globally consistent uh
things happening such as continuous uh
motion like this all right yes yes yes
so we saw this uh temporal super
resolution between the key frames
generate the missing data between the
key frames in non-overlapping
segments well so the ability to generate
globally coherent motion using temporal
Cascades is inherently
restricted the base model so the base
model generates an aggressively
subsampled set of key frames in which
fast motion becomes temporarily Alias
and thus ambiguous the ambiguity being
there are multiple ways to reach from
one key frame to the next key frame and
the local temporal super resolution
model has to make a choice and because
of memory constraints it cannot look at
all of the other it cannot make this
Choice globally or in global agreement
yeah okay that's that's what I said
thanks paper and lastly they say
cascaded training regimens suffer from a
domain Gap where the TSR model is
trained on real down sampled video
frames but at inference time is used to
interpolate generated frames which
accumulates errors that supposedly more
minor uh problem but also plays in here
they say they circumvent that by using a
space time unit which they call stet
that learns to down sample the signal in
both space and time and performs the
majority of its computation in a compact
SpaceTime representation this allows us
to generate 80 frames at 16 FPS or 5
Seconds which is longer than the average
shot duration in most
media so yeah we have to discuss a
little bit what it means to do video
generation right this here is not really
video generation like yes the it meets
the technical definition of video
generation but 5c it's like 5sec
animated pictures right that's it's
different in my opinion
from true video generation in sort of
the sense that you would understand it
if someone on the street told you hey I
have a model that is text to
video for whatever reason someone on the
street might tell you that um so they
they try to they try to Hype it up still
you know knowing that yes 5 Seconds
still is is not super long by saying
okay this is longer than the average
shot duration in most media
so yes true but these shots in most
media they themselves are then globally
consistent across a 10minute segment um
and yeah so debatable whether that
is really a fair or a a useful thing to
say um this graphic I find helpful on
the left hand side and extremely
unhelpful on the right hand side uh so
it's just like okay we don't do key
frames it doesn't yet tell you anything
to use up like a quarter of a page for
this um yeah I guess
that's that's okay but as you can see
they just d directly generate all the
frames right here and there is a smaller
difference as well if you look here uh
and you look at the boundaries between
the segments this is generated so here
you can see um the spatial super
resolution just operates on these kind
of independent slices and in this model
right here the spatial super resolution
operates on overlapping slices this is
completely independent as far as I
understand of the um technique above
like you could totally do that on the
left hand side as well I feel um because
it's just you know how do you apply the
spatial super resolution model that
upsamples the frames in their Dimension
so the spatial super resolution model it
and it has the ability to look at the
neighborhood of these frames while doing
so right it so it always looks at a
chunk of frames and and what they do
differently it's like this is
contribution number one up here and
contribution number two is they say okay
we do this in an overlapping way so it
avoids the boundary artifacts that might
happen at the boundary in the classic
sense this there is a reason why they
stress this part so much and they
mention that we also do this and I'll
tell you later because it's quite funny
um but that process is now called multi-
diffusion I know I'm I'm hyping this up
uh so this is the yeah so yes yes yes um
because they mention it already here so
they say in our model the model Works in
pixel space consists of a base of a base
model followed by a spatial super
resolution Cascade uh and then there is
a long text you can see okay the SSR use
temporal windowing approach yada yada
lead to inconsistencies and appearance
at the boundaries we propose to extend
multi diffusion uh an approach proposed
to achieving Global continuity in
panoramic image generation to the
temporal domain so that's describing
contribution number two right here all
right back to contribution number one
this is the general architecture of the
model you will if you are have been in
this space for a bit you will recognize
this to be a sort of a unet shape um a
unet usually is think of think of an
image Auto encoder so you get in you put
in a training image and you want to
reconstruct that image right um so there
there's some sort of model right here
that usually compresses it to some lower
representation and then extends it again
to some higher
representation now in the case of
diffusion model
what you do is you put some noise on
that image and then you try to
reconstruct the unno the denoised image
and you do that in various level of
noise the whole model right here is
going to be a diffusion model so the
this Cascade right here is as far as I
understand it at inference time you go
through this many times so you start
with complete noise and then you go
through this you get a slightly less
noisy version and then you go back you
go through this again you get a slightly
less noisy version and so on so you you
do this multiple steps like in a
diffusion model except you do it on the
whole video at once uh so keep that in
mind but we're just going to take care
of that single step right now so the way
the unet works is by saying okay I'm not
going to work at this full resolution
scale I'm going to process the image and
down sample it in a learned way so the
there's a learned down sampling you can
do that with a strided convolution or
something like this and I'm going to
make that initially it has three
channels right has red Channel blue
Channel green Channel I'm going to
process this and get this to a lower
representation lower usually you if this
is width and height you do like width
half and height half so you get a
quarter of the pixels but now you can
have many many channels in this image
this is no longer an image this is now
like a latent representation of the
image that just also has some spatial
Dimensions but it has many channels like
many latent Dimensions um and then you
do that again so you process it and one
step of the processing is a learned down
sampling step so you are really small
and then you have maybe even more
channels so as your spatial resolution
goes down your number of channels goes
up and then eventually you can do some
processing in this latent space that's
usually where latent
like you can apply sequence models right
here which they will do as we'll see and
eventually you'll do learned upsampling
again learned upsampling again until you
reach the the final size again there are
some skip connections along the way and
you have a loss that essentially says
well these two either should match or uh
what whatever you output on the right
hand side should be the match the den
noised the original un noisy version of
the noised image on the left depending
on what your loss
is now why did I just draw exactly their
architecture again like couldn't I have
just pointed to their picture no this
here is text to image and this down here
is text to video and what they do even
though it looks the same it is not and
that's because they add an extra
Dimension here you'll see that the
actual tensor they have is four
dimensional or yeah so there there are
four axes to the tensor there's height
and width and there is the
dimensionality so this is like RGB on
the highest level but then is some
hidden Dimension down here but then
there is another one the time dimension
so when they draw a stack of images like
this they mean time they mean the
temporal Dimension so this is the whole
video all the frames of a video is are
stacked here and each of those frames
can have multiple channels you just
can't depict that as a 3D schematic on a
2d PDF uh you can't depict four
dimensional things but imagine that
essentially this whole stack is
replicated um for for each of the Hidden
Dimensions so there there's going to be
a red a green and a blue channel here on
the lowest level but there is going to
be many many channels more on the lower
levels so not depictable but it is
different than text to image so it adds
an extra
Dimension um but the rest is the same
now the trick here or is
that they apply this down sampling of
height and width like this learned down
sampling they also apply it in the time
Dimension you can see the latent
representation is not only half as high
is not only half as wide but is also if
you consider it to be a latent video
kind of is also half as long or or maybe
has half the frame rate or something
like this right so as you down sample
you also down sample the temporal
Direction and as you do upsampling
learned upsampling that is you also
upsample the temporal Dimension so you
get longer again how do they do this um
they build layers like this so there's
this these are this is coming purely
from the pre-trained text to image model
so this is these are layers that and
there probably many layers so this does
not do justice there's probably this is
probably the small part and then this
here is probably the big part so there
are layers from the text to image unit
that they just slap in here and I'm
going to guess they just apply them
independently to all the frames of the
video and then there are some other
stuff here which is I guess all of this
they just introduced no sorry not this
um um all of like these layers they
probably just introduced because they
found it necessary so these spatial
layers here they have they're going to
have 2D convolutions just in sort of in
the spatial Dimensions um then they
threw in a 2d convolution again possibly
because they it helped um and
then they add a 1D convolution and that
1D convolution is a convolution over the
temporal Dimension so they don't do 3D
convolution they just don't naively
extend the unit to another dimension
they do what's called a factorized
convolution where they say okay we have
one convolution working in 2D which is
like this classic image convolution we
do that on a on each frame separately
and then they have a 1D convolution that
just works across the um the time
Dimension but as far as I can can tell
and they don't say anything else this is
just
considering I would guess it's just
considering a single Pixel kind of but
in all the frames like the same pixel in
all the frames or well if you want to
call it pixel in the latent
representation I don't know but sort of
the same spatial location in all the
frames and then it makes it does a
convolution across those okay so I hope
that's kind of
clear there are convolution layers and
then at the lowest layer down here when
they are really compact they now perform
attention layers because now they're
compact enough to do some heavy duty
processing again they have pre-trained
layers from the text to image model
these are spatial layers I'm going to
guess they're also convolutional I don't
know they don't tell um but then there's
a 1D attention so that 1D attention
conceivably also runs across the
temporal Dimension and can now do some
Global Information exchange Global
consistency uh in that very very latent
representation you can see they have L
of these so they have when once you're
in this latent representation you're
going to take this and you're going to
push this through a stack of attention
layers and out comes a same sized Global
sorry the my pen from the iPad is kind
of weird uh out comes a another
same-sized latent representation but if
you've done everything correctly this
will now be kind of a this will now
represent a globally consistent
video just downsampled
to smaller width smaller height and
small smaller temporal resolution now if
you're like
me if you're like me and your we like
wait a minute we started with a lot of a
lot of frames okay and now we're kind of
at very fewer frames and we're sort of
doing Global processing on these fewer
frames and now we're just going to
upsample them again in a convolutional
way right um so out of out of at the
bottom you maybe have four frame or what
is 80 frames in total I don't know you
have
like eight frames right let's say four
at the bottom you have like four frames
if you will uh then you upsample that by
two and you have eight frames in the
next layer and so
on aren't those just key frames like
isn't the bottom like the most bottom
representation isn't that just like
analogous to key frames isn't this just
like a latent key key framy thing so I
can see the advantage cuz if you do the
actual key frame method you construct
the explicit RGB key frames uh and then
you they they cannot carry any
information about the global nature of
the like scene but
but it's still kind of key
frames except here down here at the
latent space and given that this is
convolutional here's here's the point
right if you have if you then generate
even more frames because of this is
convolutional the way that this Frame
and this Frame communicates and achieves
Global consistency is purely via the
Cascade um via the convolutional field
of view
Cascades through the bottom layer there
is no way for these two pixels to
achieve kind of global consistency um in
the layer that they're in they're purely
relying that these here are globally
consistent and therefore the
deconvolutions will sort of adhere to
that but that is a much longer path of
information than just a direct kind of
global agreement so yeah this is you get
the same problem as always with
convolution in that if you generate an
image and that image is the result of
some kind of up sampling process from a
latent small representation then that it
is really hard to achieve Global
consistency in the image itself and
that's why some diffusion models operate
in pixel space directly right because
there you you can conceivably achieve
better Global
consistency so my point is like a little
bit
that if you tell me oh we generate all
the frames at once I'm yes that's true
however what you do here is also sort of
generate key frames in a way and then
you upsample the you upsample the in
between frames except you do it in this
cascaded way carrying latent information
instead of doing it explicitly uh
without any chance of global
consistency all right I hope that
cleared some things up so
start out with a big tensor all the
frames stacked you sample it down in
both space and time in a learned way you
sample it down more and more and more at
the very bottom layer you do some
attention layers uh for to achieve kind
of what you want in in sorry and there
you can achieve Global consistency
because ATT tension everything can
access everything and then you do
convolutional upsampling again through
multiple steps until you reach finally a
uh a video video sequence a tempor a
temporally extended video sequence in
the original
resolution when I say original
resolution what I mean is 128x 128 so
this entire models operates at 128x 128
scale and now the goal is still hey
let's make a video that actually humans
want to look at so how do we go from
this to a video that's 1,24 by 1,2 4 uh
so that's the the job of the second
thing in the model right here the
spatial super resolution thing right
these are actually you know these are
these are two completely different
different papers different ideas right
the paper could be done here and we're
just okay for now we can do 128 by 128
but then there is this second step of
spatial super resolution um to make make
nice websites all right how do they how
do they do
this oh yeah first I think it's
important to again highlight that the
basis of all of this is a pre-trained
text to image model right the heavy
lifting that this does is done by these
layers like here and the layer here not
layer layers right from these are
pre-trained text to image layers so
essentially what this model does is it
relies on the Learned text to image
model to produce images and image
signals and latent representations that
are good at text to image and then it
uses a few learned parameters like
2D like a extra 2D convolution and an
extra time convolution to sort of make
a smooth video that sort of transitions
uh according to to maybe also according
to a prompt and according to the
training data but the heavy lifting is
certainly done by the pre-trained text
to image
model they say we train the newly added
parameters and keep the weights of the
pre-trained text to image model fixed
which then lends itself to this thing
over here where they do styliz
generation but that in a second first I
want to talk about this this um SS this
spatial super resolution
Network so they say the spatial super
resolution Network and inflated but
inflated they always as far as I
understand it they always mean we take
text text to image stuff and we make it
we modify it to do text to video stuff
right while sort of making use of the
pre-trained text to image weights I I
think that's what they mean by
inflated so they say this can only they
operate only on short segments of the
video so it its job is to take a series
of frames uh that are low resolution and
generate a series of frames that are
high resolution to essentially upsample
them why can't it just look at a single
frame because it wants to make the
upsampling consistent if you add details
you would like those details to be
consistent across the video you upsample
however due to memory constraints you
can only look at a small segment at a
time so
that's the problem we're facing in this
part of the
paper to avoid temporal boundary
artifacts so the boundary artifacts are
okay we use the model to look at the
blackbox frames right here and then we
use the model again to look at these
ones right and we upsample them well how
do you how do you ensure that at the
boundary here you also do something
that's consistent completely separate
problem from the one before but they
decide to also tackle that we achieve
smooth transitions between the temporal
segments by employing multi- diffusion
what is multi- diffusion multi-
diffusion is the
following so that paper considers um
considers what if I want to generate a
really big image but I only have
diffusion models that can generate sort
of parts of that and then okay these
parts might even be overlapping how do I
make sure that these parts here that are
generated are globally consistent and
they formulate this as okay I have this
diffusion model and I I get in some
input and then I have um yeah they they
formulate this as an optimization
problem where I can have this in a
parameterized fashion and then I can
have some some loss around you know what
I do like okay I'm going to find the
best
best the best Global image According to
some loss and um According to some
parameters which might even be learned
that kind of minimizes this loss so the
loss could be a perceptual loss the loss
could be something else what I want to
say is this
paper that paper formulates this as kind
of a general optimization problem saying
hey we need to make sure that these
regions match in some way and it can
even be that we this is a learned
procedure right we learn some parameters
of how we should mix the different
predictions from the diffusion
models that's multi-
diffusion so what they do is they say we
split the noisy input video into a set
of overlapping segments so these ji are
overlapping segments uh with a temporal
duration that is shorter than the full
video
to reconcile the per segment predictions
we Define the result of the D noising
step to be the solution of the
optimization problem this one right here
okay as far as I understand it this here
is the noisy video segment this here is
a com the combination of the full model
so this here is the unit Plus plus the
super resolution so whatever comes out
of this is kind of the the prediction
for that particular segment of video and
then obviously the I here and then you
will have another one I + one and these
two overlap here so what should you
do how should you this here they call J
Prime how should you make the whole
video well the whole video is going to
be the one that minimiz izes the squared
Norm
between you know itself and all of the
predictions individually if you sum them
up now the astute observers among you
will realize that this optimization
problem here um in the way that's framed
here which I know is different from
having a general loss and parameters and
so on the way that is framed here can be
solved by a kind of unknown mathematical
mathematical concept called the mean
okay um it's obscure but that is in fact
the closed form solution to this
optimization problem
now why do they
spend multiple paragraphs of this paper
including formulating this as a giant
you know build it up as an optimization
problem and so on if they could just be
like yeah we average this stuff
[Music]
um so multi- diffusion is a paper by an
author called Bart
[Music]
tall would you look at
that so it is it is it took a lot of
work but Omar here really got an extra
citation uh to his pre previous paper
out of this by reformulating the concept
of the mean in such a convoluted way
that it warranted an actual uh citation
and I wouldn't be surprised if if this
here is not necessary at all and the
whole the whole oh it's so terrible to
have boundary artifacts is just in here
to get that
citation a bit Shady but also a bit
clever all right what what can you do
with
it all right so this
is this part here is what I find to be
quite cool um and I've shown you this
before in the website uh they say hey
since we only train the nulle added
temporal layers and we keep those text
to image layers fixed we could
substitute these weights with a model
customized for a specific style to allow
videos to to allow us to generate video
with the desired style however they say
if we do this with our trained model
that there's like distorted static
videos and so on um and they say this is
probably because of a deviation in
distribution so yeah if you just swap
out some layers then you're probably in
an out of distribution regime for the
rest of the layers because they did
train okay there will be the pre-trained
layers and then they're like some they
trained and then they're pre-trained
layers again and then some they trained
and so on so if you just swap out these
you'll like the signal to these layers
and then the signals to the layers down
in the line they'll change and probably
without fine-tuning might not be as good
so they say in our case what we have to
do is we have to interpolate so they're
the original text to image weights and
then there are the ones that are a style
fine tune of those and we sort of linear
interpolate between them and that seems
to work if we choose that coefficient
manually keep in mind this works because
this here is a fine tune is in itself a
fine tune of these weights right here
and so you could expect and there's some
theoretical evidence in neural tangent
kernels and so on um that that these
will will that will kind of
work I want to say by the way um if
we did discuss this paper including
these references and and
explanations um in our weekly Discord
paper discussion every Saturday evening
Europe time uh we have that and a lot of
the things that I'm telling you here are
actually not from you know me personally
but I get a lot of input from the
community there for which I'm very
thankful so if you're interested in
discussing papers uh once a week join us
on Saturday evening
they describe here what happens if you
do that and I've already shown you
before like okay for more realistic
Styles such as watercolor painting it
results in realistic motion others less
realistic spatial priors uh like for
Vector art styles result in
corresponding unique non-realistic
motions line drawing Styles results in
animations that resemble pencil Strokes
drawing the described scene why is that
and I I thought about it a bit and the
way I could explain that right it is
really special that because you would
expect you would expect that these
things right here they sort of will
generate video in a similar fashion if
you have kind of the same prompt
and but just because the text to image
model is different what I can imagine is
in the training data there will already
be some sort of pencil stroke videos
that actually show videos being drawn
Stroke by stroke right so um that is a
terrible horse but there will already be
some of those videos so these layers
will already have a concept of pencil
stroke drawing videos and then when you
swap out the models the latent signal
that comes this way essentially says hey
this is um this is a pencil stroke
drawing that I have here and then the
video layers will sort of swap on those
parts of their learned distribution that
correspond to to pencil drawings so I
believe the way this works even though
it's astounding but the way this works
is because there is already some of
those kinds of videos in the orig in the
training data of the of the text to
video model so the video layers already
know what to do with a signal like that
so if you swap in the image layers to
produce that style that the video models
will kind of adjust that's the way I can
explain it but maybe you have a
different explanation they also go over
conditional generation where they now
also include a mask like a conditioning
signal um conditioning video and the
binary mask and then they fine-tune uh
fine-tune this different Model F tun our
base text to video model to denoise the
uh video they want to produce based on
the mask and the conditioning video and
you can do various things with that um
I'm not going to go into that but if if
you want to know exactly how how that's
done uh the text is here and explains a
little bit what they what they did but
you can f tune in various ways to
achieve various
results now this is what we're all here
for how do we reproduce this okay we
train it that's cool we can do that we
train it on a data set containing 30
million videos along with their text
caption that that's it that's all you
get how long did you train it how big is
the model what's the pre-trained text to
image model what's in this data of 30
million videos what what the you know
what the how big are the layers um how
many how how many layers we told you
look at look at this
clearly
it's l layers so you know what do you
want how is this not producible just
type
L um yeah
sadly sadly science is uh has
died they say we evaluate this on a list
of prompts consists of 18 prompts
assembled by us and 95 prompts used by
prior work they have a list of that
prompt of those prompts they don't tell
us which one is which I guess you can
just go look at the prior work yourself
to figure out which of the 18 prompts
are new why they added 18 prompts we
don't know what's the performance
difference between those 95 and the 18
new ones we have no idea um they just
they give us some results right here now
I have to say these are sort of score
scores um fresh a video distance I
believe and so on these are kind of
automated scores and if you're at this
quality of video generation these
numbers really don't mean anything
except that the overall statistics of
the generated data is kind of sort of a
bit similar like the overall statistics
of real data like some statistics so
other than that I would not lend these
numbers any Credence or any notoriety
you can see this their their model does
well in them but what does it mean who
knows this is quite interesting so they
gave them to people and ask people in a
one-on-one comparison to rate uh either
their model or a Baseline and you can
see that people generally prefer theirs
um the video video quality question ask
something like which is better which has
more motion and so on so it's a bit
guided but the text alignment just
essentially asks which one adheres to
the text better and you can see that
there is a clear clear winner in this
although I have to say I also have a
criticism for
that they say participants were
presented by with a randomly selected
pair of videos one generated by our
model and the other one by one of the
Baseline methods one of the Baseline
methods so it's either they don't tell
us which I don't believe why they
couldn't just tell us which of the
Baseline methods what I much rather
believe happened right here is that they
just took one of these
baselines and generated one and then
what you see over here is kind of like
a like the the orange ones they they're
sort of mixed between different Baseline
models so obviously you can make your
model as good as you want but just keep
adding trash Baseline models so they
pull down the mean sorry the very
complicated multi- diffusion
optimization solution and uh and then
you your your model is arbitrarily
better which I also find a little bit
shady I I have to say but I'm going to
believe and also I guess if you look at
the videos you can see this is a
Improvement and a big step forward in
text to video
Generation all right the last fun thing
oh the societal impacts statement it's
beautiful it's really beautiful it's as
short as possible and it I if you're a
follower of this channel you will know
that they always are they go technology
good technology bad technology biased is
the most compact one you can imagine
um yeah that's it in the appendix you'll
find uh list of prompts user interface
these are the prompts they evaluated and
so on but that's the the paper so is
this a very cool work yes uh does it
outperform probably lot or most or even
all of the other things that exist
probably yes too does it have some shady
aspects
definitely uh let me know in the
comments what you think and yeah if
again if you're interested in paper
discussions uh every Saturday evening on
Discord see you around bye-bye